so finally a trailer has been released
that is definitely worth talking about
that is the trailer for Captain America
the Winter Soldier that's gonna be
coming out next April know obviously I'm
interested in this movie because I'm a
nerd
you know I'm just a giant nerd so of
course I'm curious about what they're
doing with this movie I enjoyed the
first Captain America film I think it's
a fun piece of entertainment I think Joe
Johnston did a really good job at the
movie but for the most part it wasn't
like this great oh my god had to watch
this every week type of film it was just
a fun watch and I enjoyed the character
and it was a good lead-in to the
Avengers which is really where Captain
America was like yes that guy is awesome
and what I like about what they're doing
with Marvel and what it seems like what
they're doing with this movie is they're
really giving shield a lot of attention
and it's not just like we're just gonna
have this big agency filled with really
cool powerful people you can tell that
there's like a political thing going on
in this movie trailer where you feel as
if this could be more grounded in
reality than your average superhero film
and that's the best way to make a great
superhero film in my opinion because
when you take this big awesome story
with these huger than life characters
and you add a dose of reality in there
that makes it feel as if it's real
that's where you got a good movie and I
feel like from this trailer that they're
going in that direction because you got
Robert Redford in there which
automatically adds a little bit of
credence to it which is pretty cool and
of course Nick Fury and they're talking
about like the difference between
freedom and fear and that's one of the
themes that I hope is present during
this movie that it's not just a big
superhero extravaganza which you know
could be awesome but I want them to be
able to go deep into what Captain
America actually has like in the comics
where it's not just a super soldier who
can kick a lot but there's actually a
lot of stuff about politics in there and
that's really where Captain America is
rooted and it seems like they're really
going in that direction with this
trailer which I am very happy about okay
so we've talked about the themes the
stuff that I think looks pretty cool and
that I hope is going in the correct
direction how does it look as a fun
summer movie pretty awesome the special
effects are already looking good
convincing which is good because this is
just a trailer and they're obviously not
completely finished you get a little
preview of the Winter Soldier in there
just enough to get you anticipating that
fight the trailer also seems
and the Nick Fury is gonna get in some
serious danger and end up in the
hospital because this one shot in the
trailer I'm pretty sure that's Nick Fury
in the hospital bed and towards the end
of the trailer it looks like the Winter
Soldier blows up his car so that's
something that could make us really hate
that character which is cool because to
have a villain in a movie like this
nowadays they have to be really
memorable because there's so many
memorable superhero villains at this
point that you have to really do
something to make the audience be like
yeah I don't like him yeah Captain
America mmm
Winter Soldier nevertheless I am looking
forward to this movie and I do think it
looks like it's going in a good
direction it looks like a fun movie but
it also looks like it has a good
political sense to it which is something
that really helps Captain America feel
more relevant what do you guys think of
the trailer let me know below and as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck Nuys